the following is a conversation with Sam
Harris his second time on the podcast as
I said two years ago when I first met
and spoke with Sam he's one of the most
influential pioneering thinkers of our
time as the host of The Making Sense
podcast creator of the waking up app and
the author of many seminal books on
human nature and the human mind
including the end of Faith the moral
landscape lying Free Will and waking up
in this conversation besides our mutual
fascination with AGI and free will we do
also go deep into controversial
challenging topics of Donald Trump
Hunter Biden January 6th vaccines lab
leak Kanye West and several key figures
at the center of public discourse
including Joe Rogan and Elon Musk both
of whom have been friends of Sam and
have become friends of mine
somehow an amazing life trajectory that
I do not deserve in any way and in fact
believe is probably a figment of my
imagination
and if it's all right please allow me to
say a few words about this personal
aspect of the conversation of discussing
Joe Elon and others
what's been weighing heavy on my heart
since the beginning of the pandemic now
three years ago is that many people I
Look to for wisdom in public discourse
stop talking to each other as often with
respect humility and love when the world
needed those kinds of conversations the
most
My Hope Is that they start talking again
they start being friends again they
start noticing the humanity that
connects them that is much deeper than
the disagreements that divide them
so let me take this moment to say with
humility and honesty why I look up to
and I'm inspired by Joe Elon and Sam
I think Joe Rogan is important to the
world as a voice of compassion and
curiosity and open-mindedness to ideas
both the radical and mainstream
sometimes with humor sometimes with
brutal honesty always pushing for more
kindness in the world
I think Elon Musk is important to the
world as an engineer leader entrepreneur
and human being who takes on the hardest
problems that face humanity and refuses
to accept the constraints of
conventional thinking that made the
solutions to these problems seem
impossible
I think Sam Harris is important to the
world as a Fearless Voice who fights for
the pursuit of Truth against growing
forces of echo Chambers and audience
capture taking unpopular perspectives
and defending them with rigor and
resilience
I both celebrate and criticize all three
privately and they criticize me usually
more effectively for which I always
learn a lot and always appreciate most
importantly there is respect and love
for each other as human beings the very
thing that I think the world needs most
now in a time of division and chaos
I will continue to try to mend divisions
to try to understand not to ride to turn
the other cheek if needed to return hate
with love
sometimes people criticize me for being
naive cheesy simplistic all of that
I know I agree
but I really am speaking from the heart
and I'm trying
this world is too [__] beautiful not
to try in whatever way I know how
I love you all